buongiorno
era il primo agosto dell'anno 2008
era il mio primo giorno di lavoro
all'istituto regionale rittmeyer per i
ciechi di trieste ero molto emozionata
ero così emozionata che per i primi
giorni accompagnavo tutti gli ospiti in
tutti gli angoli diversi dell'istituto
per far mio lo spazio le abitudini le
persone gli utenti i miei ragazzi
disabili visivi ma anche le persone
diversamente giovani che noi ospitiamo
quello che ancora oggi mi colpisce ogni
giorno entrando all istituto rittmeyer e
l'atmosfera calda ed accogliente che ci
si trova
per me è proprio per me lavorare
affinché le persone che noi aiutiamo
ogni giorno possano vedere risolte
alcune delle proprie problematiche e un
successo e un successo quotidiano è il
motivo per cui mi fa andare a lavorare
ogni giorno
il pensiero non è stato mio non c'ero
allora era il pensiero della baronessa
cecilia rittmeyer
lei è deceduta il primo marzo del 1911
aveva pensato anche se in famiglia non
risulta ci fossero persone con
disabilità visiva quanto piuttosto
probabilmente per un motivo religioso
lei il marito erano entrambi protestanti
e quindi la beneficenza è qualcosa che è
insita nella religione che professavano
in due religioni diverse veramente e
avevano deciso e poi lei dato che il
marito morì prima decise di lasciare e
lasciò per la sua città così lei dice
nel testamento è uno spazio da adibire
ad asilo per poveri questo dice la
baronessa e allora ci lasciò il suo
palazzo il palazzo baronale quello dove
oggi a trieste per chi lo conosce c'è il
conservatorio tartini
da subito quindi un altro anno il 1913
capirono che le attività lì soprattutto
per lo spazio esterno non sarebbero
state sufficientemente comodi e
convenienti
come dei convenienti non per noi non per
gli operatori comodi convenienti per le
persone con disabilità visiva che hanno
bisogno di avere uno spazio aperto molto
ampio che funga da palestra di vita per
quella che è la vita poi fuori dalle
porte dell'istituto
allora il comune con il comune di
trieste il fecero uno scambio e ci
diedero parte di quella che è la nostra
sede oggi
e che ci ha consentito poi di avere
anche uno spazio esterno veramente
speciale che si chiama ed è stato
inaugurato nel 2005 giardino dei sensi
il giardino dei sensi è una delle forme
di autonomia che l'istituto è
all'interno dell'istituto non da me
direttamente ma tramite l'equipe
multiprofessionale che noi coordiniamo
ci consente di dare alle persone con
disabilità visiva le informazioni le
capacità per rendersi autonomi per
vivere una vita autonoma che non sia
diversa ma che sia autonoma che consenta
di andare a fare la spesa di
lavorare di andare a prendere i figli di
accudire i figli
cosa vuol dire questo cosa vuol dire
nella vita di tutti i giorni tutti
quanti noi pensiamo che quando una
persona non veda sia disabile visivo
totale cioè sia cieco abbia un problema
di ipovisione
automaticamente gli altri sensi
entrano in azione
pensiamo cioè che la vicaria nhtsa
sensoriale la capacità degli altri sensi
di darci l'informazione che l'ha vista
non ci dà possano essere
immediati invece non è così il disabile
visivo studia lavora studia ancora e
lavora ancora per rendere queste
capacità
e da qui c'è la possibilità di essere
diversi in un altro modo capire che cosa
gli altri sensi ci fanno capire quando
l'ha vista non c'è
quando possiamo
apprezzare il valore degli altri sensi
il bello del tatto il fascino
dell'olfatto il gusto il gusto nelle sue
mille forme
immaginiamo anche che la vista e lo
sanno bene i pasticceri per esempio ci
propongono delle torte molto
affascinanti dal punto di vista visivo
che ci fanno venire in mente che si
possono mangiare con gli occhi ma
dall'altra parte anche
il colore delle bevande molto spesso una
bevanda di colore rosso ci fa venire in
mente che è dolce e magari ci fa venir
voglia di prenderla di verla ecco da
anni da alcuni anni ho avviato un
percorso legato le cene al buio perché
una cena al buio perché è un momento in
cui normalmente in modo conviviale
riusciamo a gestire delle situazioni che
ci sono comunque note tutti mangiamo
praticamente due tre volte al giorno
allora da questo immaginiamo come ha
detto francesca prima di essere al buio
di essere il buio ma di sentire delle
delle delle voci ma non riusciamo a
vedere come facciamo a capire cosa
succede dietro a noi l'udito ci verrà in
aiuto poi cerchiamo di trovare il piatto
ritrovare il piatto sarà il tatto che ci
aiuta
allora da questo capiamo come gli altri
sensi sono molto molto importanti e per
fortuna anche la tecnologia siamo
intende quindi possiamo dirlo ci può
aiutare a sopperire ad alcune delle
mancanze immaginiamo di essere entrati
questa mattina e di essere una persona
con disabilità visiva non conosciamo lo
spazio quello che la pressione vedente
fa entrare dare un'occhiata intorno e
capire dove andare a sedersi dove ci
saranno le persone che parla dove ci
siederemo noi i tecnici eccetera la
persona disabile visiva non riesce per
fortuna come dicevo la tecnologia può
venirci incontro
ci sono dei sistemi acustici oggi allo
studio è sempre più anche realizzati che
ci consentono che con sembra una persona
con disabilità divisiva di avere quello
che per noi è di colpo d'occhio entrare
in una stanza e ti viene non con la
vista ma con un altro senso cioè con
l'udito
ti vengono messe a disposizione tutte le
affermazioni di cui abbiamo bisogno
altra possibilità è il tatto filtrato e
sicuramente un senso molto importante
nel campo della vicaria nhtsa è certo
che per riuscire a capire con il tatto
questa stanza ci vuole un po di tempo
quindi immaginiamo una tempistica
diversa immaginiamo una vita legata ad
una tempistica diversa
d'altro canto la possibilità anche di
fare in modo che le informazioni ci
vengano in modi tramite i canali
differenti
vi racconto un giorno è successo che
stava accompagnando a casa una persona
disabile visiva e partendo dall'istituto
dopo un po dopo un certo tragitto
ho chiesto ma scusami non ricordo
esattamente dove abiti
mi puoi dire l'indirizzo guarda non c'è
problema mi ha risposto
l'indirizzo non è un problema noi siamo
adesso in corso italia e da qui ti porto
io a casa questo ci fa capire mi fa
capire come la disabilità visiva non
sempre una barriera
anzi può essere il momento per riuscire
a mettere dentro di noi di immagazzinare
informazioni diverse tramite sensi
diversi
un'altra cosa che io personalmente
faccia le cene al buio è quella di
capire
le voci le voci di chi sono quando siamo
al buio e cercare anche di
concentrarmi per riuscire a distinguere
la voce di una persona che parla della
voce di un'altra persona che parla
queste sono cose che normalmente della
vita di tutti i giorni non facciamo la
vista e così immediata e li disponibile
ci consente di vedere tutto quello che
vogliamo
ho
fatto un pensiero sulla diversità
sulla diversità
è legata alle professioni anche qui
insieme a me oggi mi ha accompagnato c'è
una mia collega e tecnico della
riabilitazione visiva lei tratta tutti i
giorni con le persone lei fa in modo che
il virus e residuo che noi abbiamo sia
messo a disposizione al meglio delle
nostre capacità
e questo può succedere anche a me che
comunque un po ipovedente già sono e
l'altra cosa che in alcune colleghe mie
colleghe fanno e
aiutare le persone nell'orientamento
nella mobilità negli spazi aperti e
chiusi
questa è l'opportunità è una delle
modalità per cui le persone con
disabilità visiva riescono a vivere nel
mondo
da ultimo vi lascio con questo pensiero
è meglio avere un senso predominante
che fa in modo che gli altri sensi non
siano totalmente presi in considerazione
come informazioni che ci possono portare
o invece si e diversi perché non si ha
un senso e si elaborano le informazioni
attraverso gli altri sensi
grazie